to be a atheist you have to acknowledge
there is a God for you not to be live in
Therefore your wrong your not an atheist
this is painfully stupid
if I don't believe in purple unicorns
does that mean that I there must be a
purple unicorn out there somewhere for
me not to believe in it
no that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever this is the type of nonsense
that ends up becoming a meme and
repeated and repeated and repeated
and if you take one second to think
about it
you realize it doesn't make a shred of
sense whatsoever to be a atheist you
have to acknowledge there is a God
no you don't doesn't really make any
sense I'm sorry